All right. Welcome to
the DDPS seminar, everyone.
Before we introduce our invited
speaker, let's go over some
rules and logistics. First of
all, please mute yourself during
the talk unless you have
questions. If you have
questions, you're welcome to
unmute yourself and ask those
questions. Otherwise, please use
the chat room to post your
questions so that we can address
them in training session at the
end. Second, today, today's DDPS
seminar is open to external
audiences. So no close by
discussion is allowed. And also
and finally the talk today will
be recorded and uploaded in our
YouTube channel. That's about
it. Let me introduce our speaker
today. It is an honor to host
Yasha su who is an assistant
professor at Purdue University.
The goal of Dr. Seuss research
is to breach large scale
constraint based reasoning and
Optimization with state of the
art machine learning techniques
in order to enable intelligent
agents to make optimal decisions
in high dimensional and
uncertain real world
applications. More specifically,
Dr. Seuss research focuses on
scalable and accurate probable
probabilistic reasoning
techniques that is the core
modeling of data and robust
decision making under
uncertainty. Recently, Dr. Su
has been developing hybrid
reasoning and learning
approaches in the emerging area
of AI driven scientific
discovery today, Dr. Su will
present an exciting topic, which
is scaling, scaling up AI driven
scientific discovery, please
enjoy and expect a wonderful
talk. Now without further ado,
let me pass the baton to Dr. Su
by asking one random question
since today is Friday. In order
to recommend a movie for the
weekend, what is what is your
favorite movie? What is my
favorite movie?
Shawshank Redemption
Oh yeah, I have watched that.
Yeah, that's a very inspiring
movie. Okay, stage is yours.
All right. Thank you. Thank you
for the introduction. You also
and sorry for this very long
title. Today I'm mostly going to
talk about scaling up AI driven
scientific discovery. And I am
here Sean from the Department of
Computer Science here to do so
we are in Indiana and this is
work with Nasim, Nan Chong, how
and Professor Xing, Anja and
enter you know, as from Purdue.
So, let me start by motivating,
you know, AI driven scientific
discovery. So, over the years,
there's tremendous progress in
scientific in the scientific
discovery fields and especially
with large scale simulations,
that you know, given a physics
model, you know, these large
scale simulations is able to,
you know, predict, you know,
what will happen for these large
scale physics models, and that
can be compelled, somehow it's
okay. So, that is can be
compelled with experimental
observations. And you know, the
physicist can see you know, how
well the the match between large
scale simulation and experiments
is, and if there is not a good
match, then they will go back to
the, you know, the physics
models and try to update the
model and do the simulation
again and see if and to improve
the match. And this overall, you
know, leads to a scientific
discovery, you know, loop that
you loop in between models and
simulations and experiments to
discover new knowledge. So, this
talk is mainly going to be using
artificial intelligence to
automate this process, and we
ask the question, can machine
learning be used to
automatically discover new
science? We will talk about an
end to end framework for AI
driven scientific discovery,
integrating pattern recognition
with physics simulation. We will
also talk about how we scale up
this AI driven scientific
discovery framework. So, our
approach was motivated by the
real world applications have aI
driven material discovery in
extreme conditions. So for this
application, we would like to
search for strong materials
under heavy irradiation and
extreme high temperature. And we
would like to understand the
defect formation migration in
these extreme conditions, and
this is, you know, of course,
meaning for, to discover new
materials for future nuclear
reactors. So, the kind of data
that we work on are these
insecurity experimental data,
and we are collaborating with
scientists from the Argonne
National Lab. So, which is on
you know, in the other side of
the country, that they have this
you know, Institute or
experimental setup, that
basically is a, you know,
electric microscope, and you
load your material sample here,
and then the material sample is
being, you know, baked, so, race
to a high temperature, and at
the same time, you know,
bombarded by iron irradiations.
So, under the electric
microscope, you can actually
see, you know, the
microstructure of these. So, in
this case, this is a copper,
under nanoscale. And so, there
are certain, you know, defect
clusters of these in these
copper material. And if you look
at these, you know, the look at
the these nanoclusters on the
electric microscope, you'll see
that over time, under these high
temperature and irradiation,
these void clusters, they
actually change in their related
relative positions, and size.
So, the question we would like
to ask is, you know, can you use
a set of partial differential
equations to describe, you know,
the movement of these, these
nano clusters, and that's, you
know, is meaningful for material
scientists in, you know,
understand the underlying
theory, behind these high
temperature and the irradiation
of bombardment, and come up with
new materials. So, here is a
institchu, a video of these, the
Rio Institute video of this nano
of this copper material under,
you know, 350 degrees C, and
current Ion irradiation. Now, if
you focus on some of the small
voids, so if you look at this
one, and these small voids,
you'll see that they indeed, are
moving, and they are following
some, you know, random moves.
And our goal is to, you know,
learn these physics models that
can explain their movement. Now,
I really want to say that, you
know, novel, artificial
intelligence enabled techniques
are needed to analyze these
large scale data. So Institute
experiments provides terabytes
of the data. In fact, you know,
a 10 minute, a 10 minute video
of these electric microscope,
videos, they would provide data
at a scale of terabytes. And it
will cause to, you know, 3.75
months work for a full time PhD
students to annotate and analyze
these videos frame by frame.
Even if he is working very fast,
you know, he spent, you know,
five minutes annotating
periphery. So, that's actually,
you know, really motivated our
research. Today I'm going to
talk about physics knowledge
discovery via neuro differential
equation embedding efficient
learning of sparse and
decomposable PDS using random
projection and rabbit symbolic
regression using scientific
approaches, which are some
recent work that we have been
doing. So, as I have said, the
task that we are trying to do is
we have this institute of videos
of nano voids, that they change
over the changing size and move
in related positions and We have
some annotations, every few
frames, the task we are trying
to do first is, you know
finishes the experimental is to
really want us to track the
position and the movements of
these nano voids at the same
time, we would like to learn,
you know, the parameters of a
set of physics models that can
you know, predict the, you know,
the evolvement of these nano
voids. So, this is actually from
our learned model, and you can
see, to predict, you know, what
is going to happen for these non
avoid, and you can see that it's
spatial and temporal movements
are actually close to the
original video and we have a,
you know, learned explicit the
physics model for that, how are
we going to do this, well, we
are motivated by you know, the
scientific discovery process of
physicists. So, as we have just
talked about finances, they
actually go through the
scientific discovery loop by
integrating simulation and
updating their models and trying
to you know, update their models
repeatedly to match experiment
observations with the
simulations. So, what we are
doing here, our work is really
to replicate what the scientists
are doing. However, with
artificial intelligence. In
particular, what we are doing is
we have this institute of video
frames and in the first step, we
have a recognition neural nets,
this is a you know, you know, we
use neural nets that he is
inspired from computer vision
and these neural nets, we try to
use these neural net to extract
the values of the partial
differential equation variable
values from this institute video
frames at two different
timestamps
then, you know, we have these
seconds neural net, which is
this neuro differential equation
that, that takes the, you know,
the the states of these partial
differential equation variables,
and try to predict what will
happen for for this dynamic
system at a later timestamp, and
also, we have, you know,
annotations. So, suppose, the,
the recognition lads and the
neuro differential equation that
they are both trained, then,
which means, the recognition
that he is able to extract the
values of these partial
differential equations from the
institute video data and the
neuro differential equation that
is able to simulate and it has
the correct parameters and is
able to predict, you know,
correctly what the future is,
then the simulated results, the
recognized results at a later
timestamp and the annotations,
these three outcomes they should
match. Now, of course, you know,
in the beginning when you, you
know, initialize randomly the
recognition that and the neuro
differential equation that
randomly then, you know, this is
not going to tell you, you know,
what are the states of these PDE
variables, and then your
differential equation that is
not able to, you know, readily
predict into the future. We,
therefore, and therefore, these
three outcomes they won't match,
what we do is we impose a loss
function that actually penalizes
the difference between the
annotation, the simulation, and
the recognitions. And we use
backpropagation to update both
neural nets. And, you know, our
hypothesis is, when the training
converges and the three outcomes
they match the recognition that
is able to extract the values of
the PD equations automatically
from these computer vision data
and the neuro differential
equation that is able to you
know, learn the correct
parameters of these partial
differential equations. And, you
know, in at the time we
developed this, this work If we
you know, independently, you
know, identify that you know,
this neuro differential equation
that can be used, you know,
formulated as a convolutional
neural net. But, you know, later
on we realized that, you know,
other people have made, you
know, similar discoveries as,
as, during the same period of
time, and really, you know, we
see there is a rich literature,
that actually are all about
learning physics models from
partial differential equation
trajectories from the data and
including many scientists
probably here in the audience.
And our work is, you know, we
integrate, you know, pattern
recognition, computer vision
with neuro partial differential
equation, that's, and, you know,
we would like to you know,
discover this, you know, the
states of the FIDIC systems are
automatically from the vision
data without you know, so, so,
most of these models need the
trajectories of PDs given to
them, we want to integrate
computer vision together with
neuro partial differential
equation that So, if you look at
our results, we have this Tm
video, so, this is the input and
some annotations, and we compare
our our model with a, you know,
blackbox neural network
approach. So, firstly, in terms
of tracking, so, here the red
parts are denotes the attractive
results for these nano voids, in
terms of tracking, both results
are doing, you know, quite good.
So, the neural nets is also able
to provide reliable tracking
with very high accuracy.
However, what makes it
interesting is in terms of
predicting into the future, so,
this is the result, so, if you
give a, you know, a TM image as
a starting point, and then you
ask the neural net, to predict,
you know, what is going to
happen, you know, into the
future, how is this nonopioid
going to change over time
without embedding a FedEx model.
So, what you see is, you know,
the prediction quickly becomes
non physical. So, this is, you
know, some predictions, that is
not cannot be the case, in real
materials. But then we said, you
know, this may be, you know, too
difficult for the neural nets,
because it's simultaneous, and
he needs to predict the future,
and at the same time, extract
the values of these partial
differential equations. So, how
about we, you know, we actually
feed the neural nets with the
ground truth values of the
partial differential equations,
and ask the neural net to
predict the future. And this is,
you know, the, you know, in
terms of the state of the
partial differential equation
variables. So, this is its
prediction, as you can see that,
it is still not able to, you
know, reliably predict into the
future, our approach, because we
actually embed these phase field
models, or, you know, these none
avoids none avoid involvement,
and we are able to, you know,
reliably, you know, predict the
future and the fact that these
matches with the regional
dynamics quite well. So, we also
deployed our model in the
analysis of real world Institute
video, data. And so this is the
real world data. So, it's a lot
more noisy, and we can, you
know, provides reliable tracking
with high accuracy, we do have
these, you know, sometimes these
show up, not perfectly well, but
overall, the accuracy is is
good. We also show that, you
know, our model can predict the,
you know, the evolvement of, you
know, of a new physics system
that is not used during
training. So, so it's works well
generalizing to your new initial
conditions. So, so this is the
first part of the talk. That's,
you know, we I presented a
framework For physics knowledge
discovery using neuro
differential equation embedding,
and then, you know, the second
part of the talk that is, we are
going to ask the question, you
know, how we can scale up you
know, AI driven scientific
discovery, and in this case, we
explore, you know, efficiency
learning of sparse and
decomposable, PDS using random
projection. So, identifying PDS
automatically from data has
attracted great research
interests. And however, this is
very expensive. So, scientific
simulation is already you know,
highly expensive operations and
the computations can take days
or even weeks, because it
actually you know, involves, you
know, handling billions of
mutually interacting elements.
Now, the backward learning, the
idea that I have just presented
is even more expensive, because
you actually need to embed this
forward simulation into the, you
know, the back propagation
process and that results in a
more even more expansive
you know, framework. So, the
question we are asking is, how
can we expedite both forward
simulation and backward
learning? And our answer is, if
we can use take advantages of
the province structure. So, here
the province structure that we
are looking at are really
inspired by the physics problem
that we are dealing with. So,
this is the non avoid evolvement
and this is the grain boundary
change the grain grows for
materials and all these
problems, they have a very nice
property that they are
interfacial problems meaning,
you know, all the interesting
phenomenon that you actually see
are actually in the, you know,
are actually in the, in the
boundaries of the system. So, if
you look at not avoid, you know,
the, you know, the changes are
really adds to this, you know,
the boundary of these narrow
voids, and similarly, the
changes are along the boundaries
of this you know, these Marty
gray material systems, so, not
only the the changes are
concentrated on the, you know,
on the, on the edge of the
systems, the you know, the, if
you write out the partial
differential equations that
describe the change, the partial
differential equations are
actually you know, easily
decomposed into the linear
combination of learning
parameters times you know, a set
of sparse features. So, here,
you know, the red, you know, the
parameters with the red
underline are the parameters to
learn from the data and the, you
know, the, the the terms in blue
are these the features. So, you
see that, you know, not only the
changes are sparse, the features
also sparse, okay. Now, this is
also true for other, you know,
variables in the system, and is
also true for grand gross. So,
now, if you have this, you know,
very sparse fitting system, what
you can, what you immediately
realize, is, you know, you're
dealing with a, so this is the
loss function of the learning
problem that you're trying to
learn that basically, you try
to, you know, minimize the loss,
the loss actually penalizes the
difference between the observed
update of the system and the
predicted updates of from your
current model. Now, if the, you
know, the observe the update is
highly sparse, and the features
are also highly sparse, then if
you look at this loss function,
it is actually, you know, a
gigantic sum with many, many
elements, but most of the
elements they do not have in
most of the places they don't
have any updates and all the
features also zero. So, most of
these loss terms are zero terms.
So, you are actually dealing
with a loss function That's a
lot of places you don't actually
need to worry about the change.
Now, how can we a one caveat is,
you know, if you know, well, the
loss is going to be zero, right?
If you know that beforehand,
then you can carry out, you
know, these learning in those
places in those areas, that has
only has a nonzero losses, and
you can greatly, you know,
greatly reduce your
computational overhead. However,
the problem is, you actually
don't know these terms. So,
these terms, any term can be
nonzero over learning, you just
know that, you know, overall,
there is a small fraction of the
terms that is nonzero in the, in
this loss function. So what you
can do is, you know, we use this
random projection, the idea is
to, you know, change the loss
function a little bit. So, let's
say, you know, you have these
laws, and you and we multiply
these laws with a random
projection vector, and in this
case, are the vectors of zeros
and ones. So, now, in practice
you you are not, you know,
restricted to use a projecting
vector of zeros and ones you can
actually use, you know,
different other projection
vectors, but we just use these
zeros and ones as a illustrating
point. So, what we have are
these, you know, these
projection vector of zeros and
ones, actually, due to your loss
factor, well, either basically
extract a few terms, which are
the terms in which you have
these ones and these
corresponding locations, and you
sum them up, right. So,
basically, if you project these
factor using these random 01
vectors, it is actually, you
know, group a few of these last
terms together and as well, some
of them, okay. Now, this is
actually you see that, you know,
it's not that idea, because you
are changing the loss function,
you are, you know, combining
many terms together and squirrel
some term, instead of squirrel,
sum them individually and add
them up. However, the thing is,
you know, the caveats, you
realize is because most of these
terms are zero. Now, even if you
you know, combine several terms
together, it is unlikely that
more than two or two or more
than two, you know, nonzero
terms will be, you know, you
know, grouped together, okay,
so, you are changing. So,
essentially, if you look at the,
you know, you are changing the
loss function, by grouping these
terms, you know, terms together
using this random, you know,
projection matrices, but you're
not changing the loss function
too much, meaning that it's
highly unlikely that you get
many on the row terms that is
being grouped together. So, in
fact, you know, we have these,
you know, theorem that is able
to, you know, quantify, you
know, what is the difference by
doing these projections with
these random random vectors, and
we can see that, you know, the,
the loss function, you know,
it's actually brings you a
constant approximation to the
original loss function, which
means, during learning, if you
minimize your new loss function,
which is the surrogate, it's, if
you find a you know, you know,
an optimality that minimize this
loss function it at most, you
will also find a good you know,
solution to a few minimizing the
original, highly expensive loss
functions. So, because of that,
you know, we develop this new
idea that, based on random
projections, we first you know,
random project boasts the, you
know, the features and the
spatial and temporal changes
into this compressed the space
and then we carry out the
learning you know, entirely in
the compress the space without
mo compress, you know, you know,
project them back in original
space. I want to say that the
Our approach you know, the
compression is done as a pre
processing step. So, even though
it is you know, the projection
the compressing is a costly
step, but it's only done once.
So, the overall you know,
computational overheads bringing
by the, you know, the random
projections are not that much in
terms of experiments, we are
able to see that, you know, the
our models do learns, you know,
still has really reasonable
learning performance, even after
the dimensionality has been
projected to 0.05% of the
original size. So, if you look
at, you know, these are all
these, this is basically not,
not avoid evolution, if you have
the data compressed to 0.05% of
the original size, still the
Learn model is able to simulate
similar dynamics as the as the
original, the model learned
without compression. So, sir, I
don't know if we are allowed to
ask questions during the talk,
or we will save the questions to
the
Yeah, okay, so we can pose and
then we can, you know, take some
questions. I'm actually in the
chatroom, there are some
Oh, they are okay. I didn't I
don't know how to open the chat
room. So well, actually,
what parent Daniel was posing
some questions. Do you guys want
to unmute yourself and ask that?
Yeah, Daniel should go first.
And yeah, are you there? I guess
it's not. Yeah.
Well, we can read it. So
Daniel's question is, the Nano
voids seem to have high contrast
against the background? Have you
tried any mathematical
operations to track them?
Instead of statistical learning?
Now, I didn't quite understand
that. But I interpreted it as if
you could identify these nano
voids, then you could describe
them as points and radii and
radius or something. And you
could you could describe why not
describe them as od es rather
than PDS?
Yes. So that's a very good
question. So the now did we try
to use, you know, tracking
algorithms for these, for these
non avoids? Yes, we did. And,
but what we are more interested
is in the physics behind the
nonopioid. So, so that is, you
know, the whole point of, you
know, we want to use a set of
partial differential equations
to describe that. So in terms of
whether you can actually
just say that, did you just say
that? You
know, I said, we use the
tracking algorithms from
computer vision. To track these
narrow
votes. Yes, yes. But but if you
could do that, then you could
describe the Nano voids in as,
as objects, and you could just
list as particles, and you could
use od models rather than PDE
models to describe their
behavior. And that would be much
simpler. And so it's a question
of how you formulate the
problem, would you have
formulated a problem that way,
it would clearly be
computationally much more
tractable. And so so that's,
that's what I would like to
know, I think that Daniel may
have been heading in that
direction, but he didn't, but he
may have meant something
different.
Very good question. So, I think
we can formulate the knot avoid
evolution using ODS by
basically, you know, looking at,
you know, they'll you know, the
changes of their diameters and
assume this is a you know, this
is a you know, a perfect feel,
and they are, you know, being
you know, and the change of the
diameters of this sphere and so
on. And you extract this using a
few, you know, parameters like
the, you know, the radius, the X
and Y and Z locations and, you
know, turn that into an OD
problem to process it. So, that
is that, I believe, is doable,
and it will be a good you know,
it's well be a good you know,
good model that that actually,
you know, show a lot of light to
certain degrees. of this of this
Vedic system now, but what makes
this more interesting is we
actually observe. So, if you
think about it, why the you
know, the the Nano voids
actually move in the spatial and
temporal domain is actually
because, you know, the, the rate
of shrinking of the narrow voids
in different parts of the narrow
voids, they are different. And
therefore, you know, these, the
difference of the rate actually
caused another voice to move.
And we also observed empirically
that, you know, it's not not
always sphere and they are and
in some materials, you know, the
shape of the Nano voids, they
are, you know, in some physics
systems that we are working on,
you know, they have elongated
nano voids, and so on. That's,
you know, the shape is way, way
more complex. So, it
sounds like, you're saying that,
typically, it's better to view
this as a fluid of some kind
rather than as a set of
particles, and that PDS are more
appropriate in that context. Is
that where you're heading?
Yes, yes. And it's May, you
know, it may give us more
physics, knowledge. Okay.
So in the meantime, Ravi, Abram
has, has made some comments, and
you may want to let him speak.
Yeah, Robbie, if you want to
unmute, and go have
just a just a thought on the
loss functions, right? So I
didn't see a parrot or the loss
functions, if some of them are
dominant, then you can
exclusively select them out. And
the second question is, of
course, everywhere, you're
tracking these objects in all
these, as those mentioned, they
could burst, right? So you're
not looking at some equations
where there are disruptions like
typical shockwaves. Right? So in
this example, there are none. So
it's just a simplified ODS, with
different loss functions. But if
they are not, then potentially
the bubble could burst. So that
your question is, if I have
paired to it like five or six of
the loss functions to a higher
degree or the rest, then you can
almost predict faster, but at
the same time, you should see if
there are some disruptions that
could happen.
If the destroys happenstance
isn't PDE better than OT?
And the question is, are there
disruptions in those PDS like a
shock wave suddenly appearing?
Right? We never examined those
things, but there could be
possibilities like that. It's
just a question of saying, Okay,
what's the probability that in
the current situation right now
2.5 or four or five gaps in
either collates or break apart?
Very good question. So, the, the
first part is, you know, do we
have this, you know, random
effect, that, you know,
sometimes the, you know, the
void burst and so on and so
forth? That is very good. You
know, indeed, in experiments,
we, in experimental data, we see
these kinds of things from
happening, we see these kind of
things happening, okay. And
currently the model is, you
know, the models, this, the
theoretic physicists they come
up, is they use some kind of,
you know, random effect, to
capture this, and our learning
systems are not fully capturing
that. And, but that is indeed
very exciting. That's, we want
to look into that. In as future
work, and Robbie, what, what is
your other question?
The other question is, if you
look, look at your loss
function, you're telling there's
a large sparseness between the
ones and zeros all over the
place, there's still a large
data set, right. So you also
mentioned not introducing ones
and zeros parts, let's say some
fractions, for example, some
weighted fractions, if you
really look at how this Pareto
on the larger groups are, so
imagine there are blue bubbles
versus yellow bottles, I'm just
throwing out right so then on
the interface, so you're looking
at something saying, okay, the
nature of the initial conditions
are all blues. So there's more
likely that the blues remain
right and that basically means
you're not looking at just the
large vector have waited on ones
and zeros but only a small
cluster waited on it. So then
your the learning curves that
you're trying to optimize on
will become smaller and smaller.
So you know, you can be faster
than truncheons
Yeah, I didn't quite, quite
grasp your idea. I think, you
know, probably we, let's, let's
let's put this offline and I
think you're talking about
something exciting that you
know, currently through this
Telly communication, I am not
fully grasping your, your idea,
but I think that's our
interesting ideas.
Yeah, let's let's put that
discussion later or offline, why
don't you move on? Okay, yeah.
So,
the third part is about you
know, symbolic regression using
scientific approaches. So, for
these parts, you know, this is
some recent work that we have
just been starting eventually,
we would like to actually see
this working out for learning
partial differential equations,
but we are starting on you know,
small examples of learning
mathematical equations from you
know, these you know, these
data. So, the, you know, the
starting point is, you know,
artificial intelligence has
been, you know, you know,
progressing tremendously in the
in the, you know, in scientific
domains, but, if you look at,
you know, how scientists that
are doing are learning these you
know, scientific laws from data,
they actually are very different
from these neural network models
in the sense that, you know,
they often are able to learn,
you know, these very elegant
models from you know, an
incredible small set set of
surprising data and the the
models, the learned models and
the equations, they are, you
know, highly elegant and they
are interoperable and they all
learning process is believable,
not quite different from today's
machine learning approach, that,
you know, they actively form a
hypothesis and they actively
explore you know, the, you know,
the experimental space with a
purpose. So, these you know,
these very, these different
characteristics make us made me
really think that you know, can
we you know, use the currency
you know, these neural networks
based on stochastic gradient
descent is able to give us you
know, new science, it may be
able to, you know, you know,
refine our physics models, for
example, this is the law of
gravity, you know, it may be you
know, the Refine Search on
parameters is this inverse to
our squelch or our to the 2.1
squelch also, but, you know, to
what degree these can, you know,
help us you know, discover new
physics laws, that is the, the
question that, you know, I have
been, you know, asking,
recently, so, I believe, you
know, the next stage that for,
you know, learning scientific
data from, from learning
scientific data, running
scientific models from the data
are really nice to be to have
these reasoning power to
learning approaches, that we
actively form hypothesis and
design experiments. And, you
know, goes through these, you
know, close to loop of
experimentation, I possesses,
and, you know, learning and for
this is just some starting
points of our recent work, that
we would like to explore how,
you know, control variable
experiments as a classical
scientific approach, whether
these experiments can be used to
to expedite scientific machine
learning. So, you know, this is
the symbolic regression task,
that's basically you're given a
data set, okay. So, here you
have a data set of x and y, and
you try to learn a, you know, a
polynomial, a mathematical
equation that maps from the x to
the y's. So, this is of course,
a good benchmark and making the
scientific discovery process, we
have been talking about
surrounding partial differential
equation models. This is a you
know, A simplified version of
that process. Now, this problem
is also incredibly difficult
because of the large search
space of all the possible
expressions. So, you know, some
audience have seen this slide,
but, you know, for the rest if
you happen to see this slide,
are you able to, you know,
discover what is the
mathematical equation that, you
know maps from the x to the Y?
Well, this is actually very
difficult, because, you know, I
actually intentionally make this
very difficult. But, as you can
see that, you know, this is a, a
highly non trivial problem
that's a you know, you're given
a data set and you try to figure
out what is the polynomial that
map's the input to the output.
But, you know, how about I asked
you to only look into these rows
and come up with an equation
that maps from the input to the
output
x one plus x three
Yes. So, so, I actually run
these through you know, many
undergraduate students here that
they are able to figure this
out, okay, they are able to
figure out if you just look at
the Israel's then x one plus x
three is a equation that's that
actually described, you know, so
2.5 plus 9.5 is 12 and so on and
so forth. Now, how about this
rose you know, I actually asked
the undergraduate students and
they are able to figure out that
you know, these you know, these
minus x one plus x ray is the
equation that you know, actually
you know, maps the inputs from
the output. So, if you look at
you know, minus three plus four
is actually one minus you know,
2.4 point two plus 2.2 is minus
two and so on and so forth. So,
if you have this, you know, the
Reds rows and the blue rows, you
can actually you know, you can
actually still add these
equations a little bit and then
you find out that oh, you know,
in the red arrows, the X twos
are actually are actually you
know, one point knows in red and
the blue rose the x two are set
to be minus 1.0x. And if you
look at the coefficients between
before x one, then in the red
arrows, these are the red one
point o's and the blue arrows,
these are minus 1.0. So, you
know, by doing that, you should
be able to guess oh is the
equations, you know, x one times
x two plus x three, and that is
indeed the ground truth
equation. So, if you powder
through this process a little
bit, then you will see that, you
know, this process is really the
process of you know, doing
control variable experiments,
you first hold X to be a 1.0 and
then you find a, you know, I
simplify the equation, honor
these conditions, and then you
host the, you know, the x two
into minus one point O's, and
then you see, you know, another
simplified equation, and you are
able to, you know, figure out
the equations by actually
looking at the outcomes of these
control variable experiments.
And so, you can see that, you
know, these control variable
experiments, greatly simplified
symbolic regression. I see,
there are a lot of discussions,
um, it's very quick on my
screen, so, I'm not able to
follow you know, these
discussions.
Nothing serious, it's just carry
on.
Yeah, okay. Okay. All right. So,
let me first talk a little bit
about you know, what a control
variable experiment is, this is
indeed you know, this is indeed
one of the oldest ideas in
scientific discovery. So, it is
a classic procedure widely
implemented and proven useful in
science. In control variable
experiments, you have certain
variables controlled meaning,
that in one trial, they are
whole, they are held at a single
values and then you study the
relationship between the
dependent variables and
independent variables with you
know the you know these set of
variables controlled now, the
you also have these free
variables which they allowed to
change in values within one
trial and four we assume that
there is an underlying
expression that generates the
experimental data. So, this is a
reasonable assumption if you try
to do these symbolic regression
tasks and you know when you are
working on control variable
experimental data because you
have certain variables that is
hold as constant then you know
what's its you know appears to
you is actually you know the you
know the the equations are
actually coming from a reduced
form equation that you know the
corresponding you know these
control variables are replaced
by the content by the constants.
So, as a you know first step we
recently explore these ideas of
control variable genetic
programming that you know, we
first you know, do the A we try
to you know do these learn these
symbolic equations from control
variable experiments in the
first step, we actually hold
most of the variables except for
one as constants and we try to
use genetic programming to
actually learn a you know, an
equation that links the output
from the input. So, because we
are only starting the dependence
between the outputs and one
input it is relatively easy. So,
the in most cases the genetic
programming algorithm is able to
you know, discover the correct
you know, reduce the form
equation and then what we do is
in a second step we let one
variable to bury and now, we
study the study the relationship
between this output variable and
two independent variables. And,
so, in this case, you know, we
you know, we asked her genetic
programming to extend from the
first step you know, what is the
new equation that involves these
two variables that can best
explain these, these data and
then we carry on in the third
step and fourth step, finally,
we let all the variables to bury
and we are you know, we learn a
and symbolically equation that
maps the output from all the
inputs and experimental results
actually show that our approach
is able to you know, outperform
a series of you know, approaches
from based on different ideas
based on genetic programming,
you know, risk seeking,
reinforcement learning and, and
more and more just just, you
know, let me say that, you know,
I actually, you know, discovered
this, you know, and we are very
excited about this and we
actually, you know, later on and
when we you know, actually, you
know, present this as in one of
the other values and we
discovered that, you know, one
of the pioneers, that they he
actually is in the audience
today, he actually pioneered
this approach, many many years,
in fact, like 30 years ago of
this approach, but I believe
this is the correct way of doing
science and this, this exciting
idea has been forgotten in some
in some, you know, after these
many years and instead of
focusing on building you know,
more and more sophisticated
complicated neural networks, I
think these old idea of based on
how we do science can shy you
know, in today's, you know, with
the developments of these
complicated and, you know, fancy
neural networks with, with more
computing power and so on, and
this is also this is only a
first step Next, we look at
these very limited problems of
equation discovery, symbolic
discovery, and we will, you
know, certainly push this to,
you know, more complex
scientific phenomena. Now, let
me talk a little bit about, you
know, some efforts that we want
to see if this kind of ideas can
be, you know, applied more
broadly, in learning partial
differential equations. So, here
is a phase field model, that's
actually, you know, if you
simulate this phase field model,
it's actually generates its
growth a snowflake, out of these
phase build models. Now, the
question, you know, you can use,
you know, the, you know, the
learning approaches that we
presented before, to actually
try to learn these face build
model, that, you know, that
determine this process, it is
actually very difficult because
this function is highly
nonlinear, what we do is, we try
to set up these controller
learning experiments, that we
first generate data, in which,
you know, the blue parameters,
they don't matter, they don't
matter, in predicting the future
for those kinds of data. And in
this case, the model can focus
on learning the rat parameters
alone. And then after we, you
know, the learning converge on
rank parameters converges, and,
you know, they are, you know,
they converges, we let, you
know, we generate new data that
allow the model to learn the
blue parameters. Now, if you
look at the experimental
results, so this is the ground
shoes, that's actually you grow,
you know, it's a snowflake, but
if you learn all the parameters
at once, this is what you get,
basically, you know, you get
these snowflakes that, you know,
it is still a, you know, a
dendritic certification process,
but the number of petals of this
snowflake is actually wrong,
okay, so it's a different shape.
But if you follow, you know,
this customize the, you know,
control variable learning
experiments, that you are able
to, you know, learn these
snowflake. That is, you know,
exactly like, you know, the
Gronk shoes. So, this is the
last slide, in summary, you
know, I talked about data driven
scientific discovery, learning
PD models, from the experimental
data, integrate deep recognition
networks with neuro PDE, Matt,
and I talked a little bit about,
you know, using random
projection to improve the
efficiency, and, you know, use
scientific approaches based on
control variable experiments to
expedite equation discovery. And
we deployed our message in
searching for a human learning
the nano structure evolution for
materials under extreme
conditions. And I know, there
are, of course, a lot of future
works, in terms of extending to
now expires, PD updates, active
scientific discoveries, and so
on. So I see, there are a lot of
discussions, I'm not able to
follow them, because it's
literally it's on my screen,
there's, you know, this one
seconds, and then they
disappear. So,
it's okay, I was I was giving
people references to some of the
older work, but also someone
raised the issue of dealing,
applying this this last part of
your work to handle missing
variables, things that are not
observed, but that are still
say, having a causal influence
on the system. And I mentioned
some early work we did, but I
agree that's a really important
issue. And if you have any
thoughts on that, maybe you can
tell us
yeah, that's, you know,
identifying missing values, that
would be amazing. So you know,
it's it's kind of like, you
know, you will have to identify
that you know, there are you
know, the predictions are
deviating from the from the
experiments in none, you know,
it is not caused by random noise
there is in a systematic way,
the, you know, the experiments
are deviating from the, from the
experiments are deviating from
what the model predicts. And
that involves, how you can
identify that there is a
systematic You know, mechanism
that, that that is it's a
systematic deviation. And that I
think, yes, indeed it's, you
know, probably can benefit from,
you know, causal inference and
other approaches. I don't have,
you know, a, you know, a good
answer for now. But that is very
important and, and very
important question and needs
more future work. Sounds good.
Well, any other any other
exciting discussions we need to
do? You can unmute yourself and
freely not meet that.
We've, uh, we should. I'm sorry,
I haven't followed up after the
symposium. But but I'm excited
about about this. This work. And
I'd love to collaborate. Pads.
Yes.
Yes, Pat. Yes. We should the
follow up. Yes.
Well, given the interest of the
old worker pad, maybe you want
to give the second DDPS seminar?
Sure, it would be it would be
interesting to i Well, actually,
if you go back to the recording
of the first seminar I gave, I
actually did review. Oh, but but
I could I we can we can explore
that for sure. Yeah. Then and
then you think can can can come
and he can give me trouble
during my talk.
Okay, thank you. All right. Any
other question from audience,
you can unmute yourself. And
this is very interesting. I've
gone out of academia for a very
long time. I'm in the
professional supply chain
business. So it was real fun.
Thank you.
Awesome. And your analysis
looks like nods. Well, let's
thank our speaker. Yes. Yang for
the wonderful talk. And given
the situations he has to go to
the airport to catch the plane
in a in an hour now. He was
gracious to to still meet the
talk today. Thank you so much
for that.
Well, thank you. Thank you also
for hosting me. Thanks a lot.
All right, sounds good. Um,
hopefully after this talk, a lot
of collaboration is going to be
between you and Warren deliver
more or even other external
books. Yeah, thank you, Aisha.
And this topic